hey youtubers is Charlie so if you guys
ever wanted confirmation that 2016 is
not complete garbage it's spider-man
making jokes about the flash rebirth in
an Avengers title so I'm gonna do an
explanation for what's going on you know
why flash showed up during Avengers
what's going on in that first Avengers
title and how Marvel is preparing you
for movies stuff with what's happening
in the comics right now this is a
perfect example of why I read comics you
find moments like this like laugh out
loud oh my god I can't believe they
stuck this in there but it's just so
subtle that you would miss it if you
weren't paying attention or if you
hadn't been reading the flash and you
didn't know that God speed had been the
big villain of like their first big
rebirth arc so if you haven't been
reading comics for a long time I'll
explain
Mark Waid wrote the flash for a long
long time he wrote a big big run during
the Wally West era after Barry Allen had
gone away during crisis on Infinite
Earths
before Jeff Johnson come on to the title
and did the original flash rebirth I
know there's a flash rebirth happening
in the comics right now but it's
basically a like a DC wide rebirth Geoff
Johns did the same thing with the flash
and Green Lantern a long long time ago
so next to Geoff Johns Mark Waid is one
of the most famous flash writers he
wrote some really awesome wally west
stories that the TV show is now
borrowing characters from so there's a
lot of flash history every once in a
while Mark Waid will make a joke about
the flash no matter what he's writing
but for the last couple of years he's
been writing a lot of Marvel titles so
he's doing Avengers right now they're
kind of in the middle of their own
version of rebirth just because of
Secret Wars Civil War too so they've
reformed the team and if you're confused
about why Civil War is still happening
in Marvel Comics right now but we're
already seeing this new team it's just
because the Civil War comic has fallen
behind schedule
so you're seeing stuff that's supposed
to be happening right now you should
have already read the entire Civil War
story so whatever ends up happening the
avengers basically fracture so they have
to form a new team this is that new team
you have the Nadya
wasp you have Jane Foster Sam Wilson
vision Hercules in now Peter Parker who
is a wealthy industrialist
with a bodyguard who is spider-man
funding the Avengers it looks like
something right out of Brad Birds
Incredibles like this entire Avengers
number one is so classic Avengers I love
it
the artwork is amazing the way it's
ridden is amazing this is a good example
of what a comic should be like if you
want a lesson in writing really fun
comics
Mark Waid is your teacher but I say
classic Avengers if you haven't read
really old Marvel comics like the
original Avengers stuff what happened is
is when Tony Stark was first part of the
Avengers he was the wealthy guy funding
the team in this story was because he
didn't want to reveal that he was Tony
Stark underneath the armor he still
wanted to keep his identity secret he
would say my friend Tony Stark and then
Tony Stark had a bodyguard named Iron
Man
so effectively Spider Man is the new
Iron Man of the Avengers he has this
giant headquarters in the Baxter
building he's talking like classic Iron
Man talk the dynamic is the same but
obviously it's a very Spider Man style
sense of humor so if you haven't read it
I would highly recommend you check out
Avengers number one it looks like it's
going to be a lot of fun the big t up
arc is this time war with King vision
goes after King when he was a baby
because King is a time traveler so
really the only way to get him is to go
back to the moment of his birth but it
goes sideways the rest of the Avengers
find out about it and then Kane grabs
multiple versions of himself from
different parts of the timeline and they
all go after the Avengers at the moment
of their birth so that's kind of like
the tee up for the rest of this
storyline so the other thing at the end
of number one they kind of tell you know
like these are the things that are going
to be happening this season and Avengers
is that you see them face up against
Doctor Doom in his Iron Man armor he's
in stark tech armor because he is now
the infamous Iron Man which I'll talk
about in a second but you also see them
going up against the champions which are
kind of like the rest of the other
all-new all-different Avengers forming a
kid Avengers team so you have like all
the kids in the
Marvel Universe like the really cool
ones that were in the Avengers title
split off during Civil War to form their
own team so it is confirmed 2016 is not
all complete garbage
I'm so happy like when I read this comic
not only is it an awesome story the
artwork is amazing I totally love this
you find things like this flash joke and
you reminded why it is that you read
comics like oh my god you don't really
see stuff like this in TVs and movies
people make jokes like Cisco on the
flash TV show makes Star Wars jokes but
it's not funny like this because you
would only know what's going on here if
you were current with the flash rebirth
comic book and if you knew that Mark
Waid who is writing this comic also
wrote the flash for a long time so all
these characters are written really
funny but you know you're digging for a
good story this is where you hit gold
right here but what does this have to do
with spider-man in the movies in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe like Avengers
infinity war so people say the comics
have nothing to do with the movies that
is not entirely true
we know that Marvel Studios is making a
huge push for spider-man next year
because of the spider-man solo movie
they want that to do gangbusters but
he's also going to be an important part
of Avengers infinity war so typically
you know because comics are so far ahead
of what they do in the movies it takes a
lot longer to make movies than it does
to make comic books so since the days of
Marvel phase 1 since the Marvel
Cinematic Universe started blowing up
they've used comics to sort of inception
people prepare them for big things the
matically that are happening in the
movies but specific plot is always you
know very very different so really all
you should take away from this is that
spider-man is a very important figure in
the Avengers in the comics and in the
movies he's going to become a much more
important character so like they just
want you to be thinking about spider-man
working with the Avengers so that's
happening now in the comics that will
happen in the next couple of years in
the movies but on the flip side of that
some of you will think this is a bummer
but I don't think it's a bad thing
they're diminishing Tony Stark's
presence in the comic books he's
becoming kind of this ethereal figure
he's also taking a diminished role in
the Marvel
maduk universe because even though
Robert Downey jr. is still going strong
he'll still be in a ton of Marvel movies
he will slowly be shuffled to more of a
background role like think about the way
Tony Stark is gonna appear during the
spider-man homecoming movie he's gonna
be an important part of it but a very
small part so that's also happening in
the comics right now to Peter Parker
pushed to the front now the billionaire
industrialist Tony Stark pushed to the
back so even though the comics continue
to be separate from the movies they're
just testing out ideas like preparing
you for things that are happening in the
movies with comic book storylines but
what I'll do next is I'll do a video for
infamous Iron Man number one there's a
whole lot of stuff going on
that explains why Doctor Doom was so
obsessed with Tony Stark in why he's now
using stark tech to make his doob armor
he's basically assuming the mantle of
Iron Man but there's a whole bunch of
stuff happening with the Tony Stark
character as of the end of civil war two
that explained why it is everybody else
seems to be taking stuff from him and he
doesn't seem to have any money anymore
so I'll explain that in the infamous
Iron Man video be sure to subscribe to
get that and if you guys want me to do
more comic book videos just let me know
we're heading into the end of the year
meaning a lot of TV is gonna be going
away so I will have extra time to do
more comic book specific stuff but I
would like to do that anyway it's just
it's hard to do comic book videos
without dropping some of the other
videos that I'm already doing so get
high and be sure and read some comic
books this week there's a lot of really
awesome stuff happening where you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for my Doctor Strange review and you can
click here but I get big behind the
scenes Thor Ragnarok video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys
there are two types of things in the
universe